[Music]
whoa
that's really good
[Music]
i'm beryl and again inspired by my last
video
i'm gonna try something i'm gonna have
an
international pizza party for one
i went on youtube and i said what type
of pizza toppings do you like on your
pizza and where do you live
and again you guys responded
i looked through the comments and i
picked out seven topping combinations
from seven countries
to try out the different ways that you
recommend i should eat pizza
from around the world instead of
spreading this all out over a week
i i'm just gonna go for this in one day
i think i'll be fine
i think so this is the pizza toppings
episode
so the first pizza i'm trying was
submitted from australia
they said that on their pizza they like
barbecue sauce
ham and pineapple
[Music]
i'm going to use barbecue sauce as the
base instead of tomato sauce
you always need to start with a little
bit of cheese on the base add a little
bit of pineapple
put some cut up ham and top with cheese
and put it in the oven
[Music]
okay first pizza from australia
i have actually never had barbecue sauce
on pizza before
[Music]
this is good oh good
the barbecue sauce is kind of sweet and
the pineapple is kind of sweet and the
mozzarella cheese is saltier
also there's a bunch of pizzas that have
pineapple on them so get ready
pineapple is apparently much beloved
i don't miss tomato sauce at all on this
i actually love this
thank you australia this is fabulous
this next way of eating pizza was
submitted by somebody
living in england although this is a
scottish
thing so there's two parts to this the
deep frying part that is flour baking
powder and salt
and then the pizza that you serve with
white vinegar
and french fries at the end
so you're gonna pour out the flour not
like that though clean that up
clean that up pour out the flour add a
little bit of baking powder a little bit
of salt
some water mix it up a little more water
keep mixing
cayenne because i heard that's good
then it needs to be in the fridge for 15
minutes
you're gonna have the oil heating up on
the stove once the batter
is ready you're gonna take the pizza and
cover it in the batter
carefully put it into the oil push it in
get it
nice and deep fried take it out let it
cool
plate it very nicely with french fries
[Music]
okay this is definitely my first time
eating
deep fried pizza there's a first for
everything
so i need to put some vinegar on this
okay this is so good
the batter is really crunchy this was my
first time deep frying and i feel like
it wasn't that scary there's not much to
say unless you're somebody who really
objects to deep frying
deep frying anything makes it better and
pizza is no different yum
the vinegar is good
[Music]
this is one of those things where you
have to like think the internet because
i would have never
i would have never come across this
without you guys
the next type of pizza i'm having was
submitted from brazil
this one is just shredded chicken and a
type of brazilian cheese called katipuri
so tomato sauce as the base
put the shredded chicken on top that
okay better
squirt out the katupouri and spread it i
guess
that's looking that's looking better and
put it in the oven
and it's done
so this submission came from brazil and
it was actually
in the pizza around the world video as
well so
it's all coming full circle it's
shredded chicken
and katapuri cheese which is a brazilian
soft cheese
oh this is just out of the oven it's so
hot
i should have waited longer very
interesting
it is not similar at all to mozzarella
cheese
it is very creamy like a very umami rich
[Music]
cheese
this pizza was submitted from malaysia
it is
tuna fish with pineapple again
and that was an island dressing okay so
tomato sauce base a little bit of cheese
to start out
put some tuna fish spread it around
add the pineapple a little more
pineapple
okay then cheese on top and then i'm
guessing and i'm just kind of
putting the thousand island dressing
across the top and i'm gonna bake it
like this
okay it's done
[Music]
i have never tried tuna or thousand
island dressing on a pizza the thousand
island i get
i mean
this is kind of like a really extra tuna
milk
and a tuna melt is great
if you like tuna fish then you would
like this it's a tuna melt
or maybe a tuna melt is a pizza and
we've just been calling it by the wrong
name
the pineapple is a funny addition though
because you're all like yeah i'm eating
a tuna melt like this is great
and then boom big piece of pineapple
right at you i know like i ate it
i ate all of this so
this one is called a savoy yard savoy
i can't do accents it needs heavy cream
gruyere
cheese potato and bacon
yes
[Music]
so you're gonna use heavy cream as the
base and
you're gonna put a little bit of gruyere
cheese grated on that
and then put the bacon a little more
bacon
[Music]
a little more bacon and then cover it
with thinly sliced pieces of potato
and then you're gonna put bigger slices
of gruyere on top
and bake it and it's done it looks
pretty good
this is going to be a decadent bite i
can feel it
there's a lot happening
whoa okay
why does good food make me giggle okay
the bacon is really good it mixes so
well
i put these kind of big slices of
gruyere cheese on top
which just like melts into everything
and coated the potatoes in this amazing
amazing
way it's really rich between the cream
and the gruyere cheese but then you have
this really salty
crunchy bit from the bacon and
[Music]
i'm gonna have some of the second bite i
don't know if i could eat a full pizza
like this but
split around the table yes delicious
this pizza was submitted from sweden
twice
actually it's shredded chicken with
pineapple and banana and
peanuts and curry powder
okay so tomato sauce on the bottom
a little bit of cheese as the base
shredded chicken
and then the pineapple okay then
cheese on top and then i'm gonna put the
banana on just
slices of banana and the curry powder
oh and some peanuts and
bake it looks pretty good
if i didn't know any better i would have
thought that this pizza was a troll
but this pizza is also in the around the
world pizza video
and i got multiple responses about this
topping so
this is my first time having banana
on a pizza in game
[Music]
it works
what what is happening
there's two types of fruits on here
which is definitely
one more than you need the banana
what i know what it is the banana is
cooked so the sugars
are tasting very different in it but the
curry powder
on top balances it in such a way
that it kind of almost
acts like more cheese
but not does that help
i mean i'm not i'm not like a real food
critic i don't know why this is working
okay
[Music]
it's good this pizza was submitted
from dubai and it is
artichoke hearts anchovies
hard-boiled eggs and bacon so
we're gonna do tomato sauce as the base
a little bit of cheese
okay put the artichoke hearts on top i
love artichoke hearts
and the anchovies go big or go home
we're putting four anchovies on top
and the hard-boiled egg make it look
pretty
cover with cheese and i realized that i
forgot the bacon
after i put it in the oven but we will
rectify that later
[Music]
it's amateur hour over here i forgot to
put the bacon on it and that
is a rookie move right i feel bad
but i brought it so it's not baked in
but it's still going to be a part of it
i've never had hard-boiled egg on a
pizza i've definitely had fried egg on a
pizza with runny yolk
but not hard-boiled i don't really have
much to say about the anchovies because
i find them to just be very salty
however i love artichoke hearts on pizza
artichoke hearts i think are one of the
most underrated
foods they're so good i have so much
food in my teeth right now i can feel it
whatever i can appreciate the flavors
it might not be my cup of tea but it's
not bad
[Music]
so i just woke up from a two-hour nap
it was too much pizza my body just
shut down i don't think that any of them
were
oh the light i think that this has been
really fun
and interesting because pizza is such a
universal food
and yet the toppings were so wildly
different so many of the toppings i
would have never even thought to try
myself and i think that when people
travel they're all like oh we need to
try the local cuisine you know like
let's not get pizza we know what pizza
is
no i don't think that we actually know
what pizza is
when we travel and i have now decided
that pizza needs to be
on the list of foods to try when
visiting another country
because you get such a different flavor
palette it was really fun
i'm going to include a link in the
description so that you can see all the
different toppings that people
recommended
and you should take a look and in the
comments here let me know are there any
pizza
toppings that i absolutely should try
and also what did you think
of the ones that i did try any of them
were just too crazy for you
this was really fun though i liked it
my pizza world has been expanded
[Music]